منذ بدايه الحرب على اوكرانيا لم تتوقف
الولايات المتحده عن الانفاق بسخاء على
تسليح اوكرانيا حزمه مساعدات بالجمله صادق
عليها الكونجرس الامريكي قبل ان تبدا
الشركات المصنعه للاسلحه بارسالها الى كيف
لكن تصميم الشركات الامريكيه على زياده
حصتها من مبيعات الاسلحه لاوكرانيا دفع
بعضها الى نقل اسلحتها بشكل مباشر دون
انتظار التصاريح الاداريه اللازمه من
الفينتاغور من بين هذه الشركات شركه سايبر
لاكس وهي شركه مصنعه للمسيرات
ونقلا عن صحيفه
العديد من الشركات الامريكيه المصنعه
للاسلحه كانت قد ابدت رغبه في تزويد
اوكرانيا بالاسلحه لكن شروط البنتاجون
حاله دون ذلك فوزاره الدفاع الامريكيه
تفرض مرور جميع الامدادات عبر قنواتها كما
انها تشترط ارسال المساعدات وفق حاجيات
اوكرانيا وليس بشكل اعتباطي لكن شركه سابر
لاكس المتمركزه في ولايه كارولاين
الشماليه
اخترقت روتين العسكري لوزاره الدفاع
الامريكيه ونقلت مسيراتها الاستطلاعيه
مباشره الى الاوكراني
كيف قامت هذه الشركات ببيع اسلحتها الى
اوكرانيا بدايه يقوم بعض الوسطاء بربط
الاتصال بين الشركه وكبار المسؤولين في
كييف غالبا ما يكون الوسطاء عباره عن
خبراء اسلحه بعدها يقوم مسروع شركات
الامريكيه بالتوجه الى كيب ومقابله
المسؤولين العسكريين وعرض السلاح الذي
تريد بيعه وفي حال ما لقى سلاح اعجاب
المسؤولين الاوكران فان الشركات الامريكيه
تقوم بالتحايل على البنتاغون من خلال شحن
اسلحتها عبر شركات النقل وارسالها مباشره
الى اوكرانيا
وبهذه الطريقه شحنت شركه سايبر لاكس مثلا
اسلحتها الى كييف لكن وزاره الدفاع
الامريكيه علمت بالموضوع وقامت بعدها
بتوبيخ الشركه من خلال تصنيفها كشركه
مضلله رغما تراجع قيمه اسهمها بشكل كبير
الغريب في الامر ان حزمه المساعدات
الاخيره التي صادق عليها الكونجرس شمل
الطائرات الشركه نفسها رغم التحايل الذي
قامت به ويبدو بان الامر متعلق بطلب كييف
فضلا عن الاقبال الكبير على الطائرات بدون
طيار خصوصا خلال هذه الحرب